[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: Hi, and
welcome to episode
number 166 of the weekly
Google Cloud Platform podcast.
I'm Mark Mandel, and I'm here
with my colleague, Jon Foust.
Jon, how are you doing today?
JON FOUST: Really, really good.
MARK MANDEL: You good?
JON FOUST: I haven't been
having a lot of fun this week,
so really excited to get
talking to our guests today.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Not too cold in
New York, I hope?
JON FOUST: Actually,
it snowed, and I
was able to escape the snow.
[TIRES SCREECHING]
MARK MANDEL: That's good.
Awesome.
So this week, we are talking to
Lucia Subatin and Kevin Nelson.
Lucia is a global
developer advocate for SAP,
and Kevin is a developer
advocate for Google Cloud.
We're going to be talking
about SAP HANA, which is
very exciting and interesting.
And then we'll move on to our
question of the week, where
we'll be talking about
programmatically searching
for links to an image.
JON FOUST: That sounds cool.
I've actually got to
mess around with that
when I built up my first
project when I joined Google.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
But yeah, why don't we get
stuck into our cool things
of the week?
Jon, why don't you take it away?
You've got a fun one.
JON FOUST: This
year at GDC, we are
announcing six sessions
and one workshop
on monetizing your game.
Most of the game developers,
when they create a game,
if they want to make it
completely free to play,
but earn some income,
they'll probably
introduce ads into their game.
So Google AdMob
and Google Ads will
be at GDC and holding
these sessions and mixers.
And we'll also be
at the Google Mixer.
Mark and I believe
we'll be there.
If you're going to be at
GDC, stop by and see us.
MARK MANDEL: My next
one, speaking of games,
there is now a new
game developer hub.
So if you're looking for a
singular place to look at all
the stuff for Google
Cloud to do with games,
if you go to
cloud.google.com/doc/games,
you can see a set of quick
starts, featured code labs,
featured products, resources.
Keep an eye on it.
It's just started, but I expect
there'll be lots of cool things
to come still.
JON FOUST: Yeah, I'm pretty
excited to actually be adding
some things to it hopefully.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, sweet.
JON FOUST: The next thing
we're going to talk about
is Cloud Bigtable
and its announcement
of replication capabilities
that are currently in beta.
This functionality
is used currently
by Google Search, Google
Maps API, and YouTube.
What this does is it allows
us to replicate clusters
in any zone at anytime
and seamlessly add scale
from gigabytes to petabytes.
So you'd imagine
that scaling that
high would have some
type of latency,
but this expansion
allows us to do
that with high performance
throughput and low latency
response times.
MARK MANDEL: This
one's a little bit old.
This was back on
February 20th, but we
didn't mention it previously,
and I realized that.
So Knative had its 0.4
release back in February 20th.
This is actually really nice.
Knative now has support for not
just HTTP, but also supporting
HTTP/2 and gRPC.
It also has the ability
to upgrade an inbound HTTP
connection for web
sockets as well.
So there's lots of
new stuff outside
of that also for
Knative, so make
sure to check out
the GitHub repository
and see what's going on.
JON FOUST: And the last
cool thing of the week
is being able to build with
the G Suite Classroom API.
that allows developers to access
course data programmatically,
and it allows them to build deep
integrations within classroom.
So they enhance learning and
save students and teachers
a lot of time.
The Classroom API
allows developers
to integrate applications
within their classroom,
such as apps that gamefy
lessons and interactive quizzes.
That way, you can gain the
interest of your students.
I currently use
Classroom, so I'm
pretty excited to
put my hands in this
and see what kind
of cool things I
can build out for my students.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
Well, Jon, why don't we
go talk to Lucia and Kevin
and learn all about SAP HANA?
JON FOUST: Sounds good.
So today on the
podcast, we're being
joined by Lucia Subatin
and Kevin Nelson.
Lucia.
LUCIA SUBATIN: Thank you
for having me, by the way.
My name is Lucia Subatin.
I'm a developer advocate at SAP.
JON FOUST: Yeah,
we love DAs here.
And Kevin?
KEVIN NELSON: Hi, Kevin Nelson.
I'm a developer advocate
based down in Los Angeles.
And I focus on
ecosystem partners
like working with SAP to
enable their huge development
community to learn more
about Google Cloud.
JON FOUST: And
today, we're going
to be talking about SAP HANA.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, at a high
level, what is SAP HANA?
I actually have no idea.
LUCIA SUBATIN: It's a
data and application
platform that has an in-memory
column-oriented database in it.
MARK MANDEL: That was a lot.
LUCIA SUBATIN: And I can go on.
I go on for hours.
MARK MANDEL: So maybe
break that down a little,
just like a touch.
LUCIA SUBATIN: Well, it's the
platform, which we run our SAP
business applications.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
KEVIN NELSON: I think
one of the key benefits
that HANA provides with this
in-memory database is being
able to handle large enterprise
transactions with very, very
tight time constraints.
So you're able to handle
the day-to-day business
needs, guaranteeing
that you're not
going to go out and hit disk.
So you get really good latency.
JON FOUST: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: You said something
interesting in there, too.
You said it's both a data
and an application layer.
LUCIA SUBATIN: Yes, so
traditionally, our ERP
applications, for
example, where customers
run their operations and all of
their business related stuff,
ran on any database.
So when those business
applications started running,
they were database agnostic.
And that was on purpose.
But with time, we realized that
our customers and businesses,
they really value their data.
And then you also
understand that as Google.
And we found that we
needed to provide them
with a better way
of gaining real time
insights about their business.
So for example, when I
used to do consulting,
one thing that was pretty usual
is for somebody like a CFO
to have to wait for
a week before they
could answer the question of
how their business finance is
going.
And we found that we
had to solve that,
and that was not something
that was acceptable anymore.
So we came up with this
platform that being in memory
and having columnar capabilities
and having the ability
to run advanced analytics allows
these applications to tap on
data really, really fast.
So for that case,
this specific example
I was talking about of the
week running report, that
turned into less
than five minutes,
to give you an example
of why HANA is so
important to our applications.
JON FOUST: Sounds amazing.
I'm curious, what can we
expect from SAP and GCP?
LUCIA SUBATIN: Well,
we can expect a lot.
In terms of what
we have been doing
with Kevin and some other
advocates in your team,
we have been trying to bring
our communities together,
our developer
communities together.
The developer community
at SAP is huge,
and in the different roles,
we have people who really
understand the enterprise.
And that's what we do.
We are leaders in
enterprise applications.
And at the same time, our
customers need agility.
And they need a reliable place
to run these applications.
So what we are trying to do
is bring the Google developers
in the advocate together with
the enterprise developers
and cross pollinate knowledge.
JON FOUST: That sounds amazing.
So which products would you
say that SAP HANA and GCP
specifically target?
LUCIA SUBATIN: Well, we
are talking about always
the business applications.
So all of our
business suites, like
S/4HANA, which is the
evolution of the ERP
and the C/4HANA, which
is for like a CRM.
MARK MANDEL: What's an
ERP and a CRM for those
who don't know those terms?
LUCIA SUBATIN: Oh, OK.
That's a very good question.
That's very natural
to me, so thank you
for pointing that out.
An ERP system is Enterprise
Resource Planning.
That's what it stands for.
And what it does is control all
of different areas or business
areas in the company.
So for example, you will
have there all the logistics,
the procurement,
the finance, HR,
everything that a company needs
to keep track of and assist
them in terms of transactional
and then analytics.
That is what an ERP system does.
It keeps track of it.
And otherwise, you would have
to have Excel spreadsheets,
and nobody wants that
to run their business.
Yes, that's why you're laughing.
You should laugh.
MARK MANDEL: I'm not saying I've
done that, but I've done that.
JON FOUST: Me too.
LUCIA SUBATIN: Well, if
it's just for yourself,
it makes sense.
Or if you have a
very small business,
that maybe makes sense.
But if you are talking
about a global company,
you need to really have
a system behind that.
So what we did with
ERP is have the logics
there for all of the
business areas in a company.
KEVIN NELSON: Let me plug
SAP a little bit here.
SAP does this type of software
for most of the biggest
companies in the world.
So they've had to deal
with the unique challenges
of every single business and
how to manage those resources
at vast, vast scale.
LUCIA SUBATIN: I did not
have those facts super clear.
But we have at least 25
different industries.
And I can talk about what
I implemented myself.
So I've been at an auto company.
I've been at a huge retail
company that has supermarkets
all over the world.
I've been at a company that
does over 80% of the chocolate
in the world, which is amazing.
KEVIN NELSON: Your particular
favorite place to be.
LUCIA SUBATIN: Exactly, yes.
That's why I remember it.
So I've even implemented
SAP at an airline.
So you also need to keep track
of the maintenance of planes.
So that is some of the
things that SAP does.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
Going back to what
Jon was talking about,
what unique advantages
do people have
running SAP on Google Cloud?
Is there a good thing there?
LUCIA SUBATIN: Well, yes.
Because traditionally,
we were having
all these systems on-premise.
And our customers are not
interested in doing data center
related stuff.
And you guys at Google
are great at that.
You're leaders and--
MARK MANDEL: We do all right.
Thanks, yes.
[LAUGHTER]
KEVIN NELSON: Yeah, the
world's moving to a place
where in order to be
successful, every company has
to do what they are best at.
And SAP is fantastic at
developing and deploying
these massive
enterprise applications.
Google's fantastic at
infrastructure, security,
power management, all the things
about keeping hardware running
and making sure that the
application has a platform that
can be fast, that
can be low latency,
that can be successful,
that can be safe.
LUCIA SUBATIN: In
that way, we have
business minding their own
business, I always say.
Then also, there's the
piece that's not minor,
which is being able to scale.
So if you have your own data
center, you can't scale,
but you guys provide a lot of
options for scaling and scaling
reliably.
And that is very
important when you're
running things like HANA.
HANA, being an
in-memory platform,
it needs a lot of RAM.
So it needs proper hardware,
and we did a joint effort
to certify your hardware.
So that's also why it's a good
place to run our applications
and specifically, HANA.
JON FOUST: Awesome.
I'm a very big hardware guy--
RAM, SSDs, everything.
LUCIA SUBATIN: Yes.
JON FOUST: So definitely at
the top of my list for anything
that I build.
So I have a question.
Focus more about BigQuery and
immigration with SAP HANA.
LUCIA SUBATIN: OK,
yes, that's something
that we have been
showcasing a lot.
So we have this capability of
integrating BigQuery into HANA
by using smart data adapter.
That is something
that technology
that we have in HANA that allows
us to simply go and tap and do
queries on BigQuery's
huge data sets.
So generally, we
would go and tap
into what would be probably
cold data for a HANA system
and run the aggregations
and whatever
we need to do in BigQuery.
And then move it over
to HANA to integrate it
with warm or hot data.
KEVIN NELSON: Yeah, this
really is a key capability.
Because one of the constraints
of in-memory database
is obviously, businesses
have more data
than can fit in physical memory.
So having it running in HANA
in this column database,
everything is fast, low latency.
But what do you do with last
year's data and the data
that you want to run
historical reports on?
So once that data is
offloaded into BigQuery, now
you can integrate that into
queries directly within HANA.
It's sitting there, but
then gaining the benefits
of Google's massive
scale for doing
these massive petabyte scale
queries in a matter of minutes.
So it provides a
unique capability
for looking at historical
data and joining data
across different systems.
MARK MANDEL: That
probably segues nicely
into what sort of workloads
we run on SAP HANA.
I think you've
mentioned analytics,
but now we're talking
about integrating BigQuery.
And there seems like
there's a lot of things
that this could do.
Where do you see its
sweet spot really being?
LUCIA SUBATIN:
Actually, what you're
describing as the sweet
spot is the ability
to run what some analysts
call translytical data
because the idea behind HANA
is that you do not move data
around, and that you can
run aggregations on the fly,
and not having to move data
around or persist aggregations.
And then this says,
we actually use
it to run both
transactional and analytics
in that same appliance.
So you can do transactional
and analytics.
By having the analytics,
I mean not just
aggregations as I
just said, but also,
any of the advanced pieces.
We have machine learning.
We have predictive
algorithms, geospatial graph.
You can even have a document
store on top of HANA
in the same platform.
So literally, you do not
need to move data around.
So that's why you're
asking, well, there's
a lot that you can do.
And yes, that is
exactly the sweet spot,
is having a lot of possibilities
out of the same piece of data.
JON FOUST: Nice.
And I'm actually
kind of curious.
On the flip side, what
wouldn't you use it for?
LUCIA SUBATIN: Well,
I wouldn't use it
if you only need a single
capability because it sounds
like an overkill, and if
you're going to run small data
sets because it's
also an overkill.
So the smallest unit that
we have is 32 gigs of RAM.
And I have that on my massive
computer that you saw earlier.
But I'm writing
that on my laptop.
But I ran that because
yesterday, for example, I
was playing on the plane
with some [INAUDIBLE]
to split a huge food
data set that I loaded.
But if you're just keeping
transactional, or just doing
graph, or only
doing geospatial, it
doesn't make any sense to
have this full blown database
with a lot of
capabilities on top.
JON FOUST: Gotcha.
This is a personal question.
Why is it that every
DA that I meet actually
does queries on large
data sets on food?
It's always food.
There's usually cheese.
There's wine.
MARK MANDEL: I've seen clouds.
JON FOUST: Yeah,
I've seen clouds.
MARK MANDEL: The
clouds, it's not food.
JON FOUST: Yeah.
LUCIA SUBATIN: Well, I
couldn't do it with cats.
But if I could, if I found
a data set about cats,
[CAT YOWLING] I would do it.
MARK MANDEL: We can hook
you up with some people.
LUCIA SUBATIN: OK, great.
Great.
I will love that.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
no, definitely.
KEVIN NELSON: And on
this lighter moment,
I want to point out
Lucia's fingernails here.
JON FOUST: Yeah, I
noticed them actually.
KEVIN NELSON: Did
you notice that?
JON FOUST: Yes.
MARK MANDEL: No one else in
the podcast can see them,
so maybe you might want to
explain what that's about.
LUCIA SUBATIN: Well,
I felt that we've
been doing so well
with our partnership
that I wanted to
co-brand my fingernails.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
Yeah, they're Google colors.
LUCIA SUBATIN: But I
have the Google colors,
and I have not a very
successful attempt here
to draw the SAP
logo on my thumb.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, I see.
I see.
LUCIA SUBATIN: But that is
what this would have been.
So I have the SAP logo
and the Google colors.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
LUCIA SUBATIN: And yep.
I'm enjoying it.
KEVIN NELSON: I
think it's fantastic.
JON FOUST: Maybe we can get
a picture for the banner.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, yeah,
we should do that.
JON FOUST: Maybe we
should do that, yeah.
MARK MANDEL: It's
really interesting.
I hear you talk about
SAP HANA, and then
you sort of drop little things.
And I'm like, wait, what
was that, and what was that?
So it sounded
almost like you were
kind of giving me a very
short list of features
that HANA will do.
You were talking about
geospatial stuff.
You were talking
about graph querying.
Can you give us a short list of
features of the type of stuff
that it can handle, I guess?
You were saying you could use it
as a document DB if you really
want.
LUCIA SUBATIN: Yeah,
on top of that,
you can do text mining
and text analytics.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
LUCIA SUBATIN: And there
are some combination.
Then you have the
combination of that.
We have streaming
analytics, like for IoT.
And that is something
I actually implemented
in my city of birth.
So you get information
coming from sensors,
and you can run predictive, and
you can run certain algorithms
while the information is
getting pumped into the database
as well.
So that is also another
cool feature that it has.
And one thing that
people ask me a lot
is if it's an in-memory
database, which
makes it very fast,
what happens to the data
if the light goes off?
And I can assure you that
the data is stored in disk.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
LUCIA SUBATIN: So
you were saying SSD.
Logically, yes, data
is stored in disk.
One thing about the
architecture of HANA
and why it was
thought this way is
not only the
in-memory capabilities
and the processing
happened in RAM,
it also happens
in the CPU cache.
So it's extremely fast.
And by being columnar and
combining this architecture,
you can get rid
of materialization
of data or copies of
data inside the database.
And by that, I also mean
[INAUDIBLE] for example.
So they are not as necessary
as in a traditional database.
And we found in internal
studies that once you migrate,
you get rate of 60% to 95%
of the objects in a database
because you do not need
the redundancy anymore.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, interesting.
LUCIA SUBATIN: So that's
another long answer
to this type of
capability, but it's
one of the reasons why we
are shifting our applications
towards HANA as well.
MARK MANDEL: So
if I'm a developer
and I'm like, this
sounds really cool,
how do I build on
top of SAP HANA?
Do I need to be part
of the SAP ecosystem?
Or can I just pick a programming
language and go at it?
Or how does that work?
LUCIA SUBATIN: You can pick
up any programming language
and go at it, as long as you can
connect through JDBC or ODBC.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, nice.
LUCIA SUBATIN: That's like
with any other database.
We also have an
application layer
that is based on Cloud Foundry.
So if you want to build
microservices based,
we officially support
free build packs.
And we have a lot of libraries
to connect and to enhance
that for Java,
JavaScript, and Python.
So that's another option
if you are into it.
And then it's just SQL.
All these capabilities
that I mentioned,
they're all SQL based.
So you do not need
to learn a lot.
And if you want to
deploy it, I have
to say that my
favorite options-- we
have a lot of options to
deploy HANA, specifically
HANA Express.
HANA Express is
our free version,
even for productive use.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
LUCIA SUBATIN: So up
to 32 gigs of RAM,
you can deploy it and
do whatever you want.
My favorite option of
all the many options
that we have out there to deploy
HANA is actually the GCP VM.
Because it takes
less than 10 minutes
to have it up and running.
And it's super easy to
get started with your SQL.
MARK MANDEL: Is
that marketplace,
or is that something else?
LUCIA SUBATIN: It's
in marketplace.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
LUCIA SUBATIN: So you
will find two options.
You'll have SAP HANA
presentation, and then
SAP HANA presentation with
XS Advanced applications,
XS Advanced is our
version of Cloud Foundry
that is enhanced, what I
was talking about before.
So you have both
options, but it will
depend on what you want to do.
If you want to do
Cloud Foundry, then
go with the XS
Advanced one, and then
otherwise, you can just use
the server only piece, just
the database.
KEVIN NELSON: Lucia
kind of quickly
went over one point I think is
rather important to bring up.
She mentioned that she
could deploy HANA Express
in about 10 minutes on GCP.
When we demonstrate this
at technical conferences,
and even to internal
SAP developers,
there are audible
gasps in the room.
Being able to deploy HANA
in five or 10 minutes is not
something people expect.
Five or 10 days would probably
be considered a good thing
normally.
So say this is
something that is super
important for doing any kind
of dev test applications.
Even at massive scale,
you can test applications
by spinning up an instance
of HANA in a few minutes.
You can give each developer
their own instance
to play with different aspects.
It ends up being a
critical way of changing
how companies think about
doing application deployment.
LUCIA SUBATIN: Yes, and then on
top of that, one of the other
things that we've been playing
with, especially at TechEd,
when Kevin and Casey
joined me there,
was deploying HANA and
Kubernetes, which is also
super fun and super easy.
And everybody likes it.
And again, it's very
easy for somebody
to spin up an instance,
load data in it.
And if they want, they
can just deploy one
and it will take zero time.
JON FOUST: I'm guessing
then, by the same token,
if I want to try
this out locally,
I can pull down the container?
LUCIA SUBATIN: You can pull now
the container, yes, depending
on the operating system.
Not all the operating
system are supported.
I personally run it on
Ubuntu because I like it.
You can also download a
full-blown virtual machine
and then have it run
locally in your laptop.
JON FOUST: The
funny thing is, you
use the word fun several
times in your last couple
of statements.
I'm interested in what
interesting things
that people have been
building with SAP HANA.
LUCIA SUBATIN:
Well, there's a lot
of, even outside the
running the business
and these use cases,
like the major chocolate
maker of the world,
which I find very fun,
because we established
that I like food.
But for example, one of
my favorite use cases
is the Elephants, Rhinos
and People organization.
They're a non-profit
organization in South Africa,
and they hooked up
drones and some sensors
on the different
herds of animals.
And they are using that
to predict and detect
potential poaching.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
JON FOUST: That's awesome.
LUCIA SUBATIN: So they
reduced the poaching incidents
in the monitored areas by 100%.
JON FOUST: Ooh, that is amazing.
LUCIA SUBATIN: So that's one
of my favorite use cases.
The other one is a bit more
serious or sad-related,
so to speak.
But it's still
happy in the sense
that it's related to cancer.
So with the American Society
for Cancer and Oncology
and CancerLinQ, they
started gathering
all these possible sources
of information related
to patients, their histories,
the treatments, the tumors,
characteristics on their tumors.
And they use that to help
doctors establish the best
possible treatments
based on other patients
across the globe.
And right now, they're topping
over one million records
or one million histories
of different patients.
And that is getting
so successful,
that doctors are
giving their own time
to add input to
that major database.
JON FOUST: It
sounds interesting.
I actually glanced
over an article
I think maybe two days ago, that
said that pretty soon machines
will be able to predict
strains of cancer
a lot faster than
actual doctors will.
So that's going to
be kind of amazing.
LUCIA SUBATIN: Yes, it's great.
I know we at SAP, we
also have a huge case
about genomics, crunching
data, run genomics,
which is pretty hard.
And I know that
you guys at Google
are doing something similar.
So it's great that we could
potentially join forces
toward that kind of use case.
JON FOUST: Yeah, we
love collaboration here.
MARK MANDEL: Actually,
speaking of genomics,
I know genomics are
really large data sets.
LUCIA SUBATIN: Mm-hmm.
MARK MANDEL: How big
a data set can you
actually put in ASAP HANA?
LUCIA SUBATIN: Well,
you technically
do not have a limit, because
it can scale up and scale out.
MARK MANDEL: Ooh, tell us more.
LUCIA SUBATIN: So you can make
a server bigger, add more RAM.
Or you can make a
server clusters,
add friends do that server.
So you can continue adding
data to your ecosystem of HANA
servers.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
LUCIA SUBATIN: As long
as they can scale.
MARK MANDEL: And if
you're scaling out,
I know it's an
in-memory database,
I know you were mentioning
transactional support.
Are there any
limitations around that?
Or what sort of
scaling up strategies
can you use with SAP HANA?
LUCIA SUBATIN: Well, it depends
on how you're clustering
or segregating the data.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
LUCIA SUBATIN: But one
thing that I should mention,
is that HANA does
have the ability
to recognize that data doesn't
need to be in memory as well.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, OK, cool.
LUCIA SUBATIN: So there is
something called data tiering.
And you can choose to have the
data that is more commonly used
in memory, and the rest have it
like near memory, like in disc,
for example.
So that is one
thing, you not need
to have all of the columns
in a table loaded in memory.
And actually, the
platform itself
is going to unload data
that you're not using.
So you as a developer, do not
really need to care about that.
One thing you may need
to care about that
is, data causing latency,
because you're pulling data
from different physical nodes,
so you have network there.
But it will depend a
lot on the use case
and how you're
partitioning the table.
You can choose how you
partition the table.
MARK MANDEL: That sounds
like it sort of shards it
across the different machines
and does something like,
got it, got it, got it, got it.
JON FOUST: If we
wanted to really
get started with
SAP HANA, what would
be like a getting started guide
from both Kevin and Lucia,
if you don't mind me asking?
KEVIN NELSON: I'll start.
I open up Cloud console,
go right to marketplace.
You can download and install
in a matter of a few minutes
SAP HANA with the
application environment all
ready to go and start playing.
LUCIA SUBATIN: Yes, and I'll
do a shameless plug here,
if I can.
MARK MANDEL: That's literally
the point of a podcast.
That is literally
why you're here.
[LAUGHTER]
LUCIA SUBATIN: They should
also request a Code Jam.
So with Kevin and Casey, we have
been traveling across the globe
and going to where
developers are
and showing them
how to deploy HANA,
how to connect it
to BigQuery, how
to play with both databases.
We also play with
Cloud Functions,
that we play with Kubernetes.
So we have a lot of fun.
I know I say that word a lot,
but we do have a lot of fun.
JON FOUST: I'm big on fun.
LUCIA SUBATIN:
And the best piece
is that the Code
Jam is for free.
All we need is
somebody to request it,
to contact us and request
it and we'll get there
and we'll again, have fun.
KEVIN NELSON: And we'll make
sure to put contact details
in the show notes.
LUCIA SUBATIN: Yes, thank you.
JON FOUST: It's a free use
up to 32 gigabytes, right?
LUCIA SUBATIN: Yes, yes.
The license is
completely for free,
and you guys generally
offer the trial credits.
JON FOUST: Oh, that's right.
LUCIA SUBATIN: So that makes
the entire experience for free.
KEVIN NELSON: Yeah, definitely
leveraging those $300
in free credits for any
new Google Cloud account
allows people to look
at the sort of more
production-like environment
before they have to make
any kind of service investment.
LUCIA SUBATIN: Otherwise, if
you have room to run it locally,
the minimum for
the database only
is eight gigs of
RAM in a computer.
It can get a bit
slow, especially
if you want to add a lot
of data on food or cats.
[MEOW]
Or whatever it is.
JON FOUST: Dogs.
Or probably dogs.
LUCIA SUBATIN: Or dog.
JON FOUST: I like dogs.
[BARKING]
LUCIA SUBATIN: Yeah,
I like dogs too.
JON FOUST: OK.
LUCIA SUBATIN: Yeah,
yeah, so, and pandas.
[GROWL]
JON FOUST: OK.
LUCIA SUBATIN: That works.
But you could still run it
locally or in a VM or a docker
container.
MARK MANDEL: Sweet.
Well, we're slightly
running out of time.
But before we finish
up, is there anything
else you want to make sure you
mention or shamelessly plug?
Or are either of you going to
be at any events or anything
like that do you want
people to be aware of,
anything along
those sort of lines
before we finish up today?
LUCIA SUBATIN: Yes, we will be
doing more events this year.
We will be doing more
events even including
some of the S/4HANA stuff.
So if you're interested
in understanding
what an enterprise
developer does or you're
working at a
company that has SAP
and you want to know
how you can contribute,
you should go into
developers.sap.com
and we have the
events listed there.
And we have the Code Jams
that you can join in a city.
And if we're not
going to your city,
you can request us to
come to a Code Jam.
KEVIN NELSON: We have some
upcoming Code Jams for everyone
later this week in Los Angeles.
We're going to be
doing two in Germany
in Mannheim and Munich the week
of the 18th and 19th I believe.
And then last year, Google was
represented at three SAP Tech
Ed events around the world.
These are kind of like Next.
They're huge aggregations,
5,000 to almost 7,000 people
in Las Vegas, Barcelona
and Bangalore, India.
We'll be at those events in
the fall again this year.
And look forward to exposing
a new generation of developers
to HANA running on Google Cloud.
MARK MANDEL: Anything happening
at Next, speaking of Next?
LUCIA SUBATIN: Well,
we will be there.
We will have a booth there.
Last year we did a lot of
hands-on activities as well.
So we had computers there
for people to come and try.
So yes, we will be
there, and I always
enjoy having conversations with
the audience at Google Next.
So really looking forward to it.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Well, Kevin, Lucia, thank
you so much for joining us
on the podcast today.
LUCIA SUBATIN: Thank you
very much for hosting us.
KEVIN NELSON: Thanks very much.
JON FOUST: Well, thank
you, Lucia and Kevin
for joining us on
the podcast today.
And to wrap things
up, we're going
to have our question
of the week.
And our question
of week is, if I
want to programmatically
search for links to an image
that I have, how can I do that?
MARK MANDEL: I'd been aware
of Google image search
for a really long
time, but I didn't
realize we had an
API that essentially
allowed you to do that.
So if you're not
familiar, basically it
means if you've got
an image, so if you've
got like a PNG or a JPEG
or something like that.
And you're thinking
to yourself, I
wonder if somebody else
is hosting this somewhere
on the internet?
Or where are all the
places this image is used,
but you want to do
it programmatically,
the Cloud Vision API has
a detecting web entities
and pages API that enables
you to basically plug
in the content for that
image, base64 encoded.
And then it'll
scour the internet
and send you back a response
basically giving you
URLs to say how much it
matches, as well as a score
to think of it how close
it believes that image is.
It's actually kind of neat.
I didn't know it did
this, so I'm actually
kind of excited about it.
JON FOUST: You know,
it's pretty cool.
And I've seen it done on
a pretty interesting TV
show on MTV called "Catfish."
MARK MANDEL: Oh, really?
JON FOUST: Where they actually
drag the image into Google
search and it actually
returns all of the pages
that image is being used.
So I would assume that it's
roughly around the same thing.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
As long as we can get TV
shows in, everything is fine.
Jon, what are you up to?
What are you doing?
You going anywhere interesting
or producing anything
cool that people
should know about?
JON FOUST: I'll be at
GDC next week, which
is going to be pretty exciting,
because it's my very first GDC.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, really?
JON FOUST: Yeah.
It is my very first one.
MARK MANDEL: I didn't realize.
Oh, I'm so excited for you.
OK, cool.
JON FOUST: Will also be at Next.
And this is my second go-around
at Next, so I had a lot of fun
and met a lot of people, so I'll
be glad to see a lot of folks.
And ECGC, that'll be
interesting for me.
I'll be strictly attending,
so it should be pretty fun.
And Vector Conf 2019,
I will be there.
As well, I'll be giving
a series of talks
to a bunch of high
school students
and a lot of large companies.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic, awesome.
So I'll be joining
you at a lot of that.
Game developers conference,
as you said next week,
which I think when
this comes out,
will be this week, just to
be confusing, which is fine.
You and I will both
be at Cloud Next.
Definitely for anyone
who's listening,
make sure to swing by the
podcast booth and come say hi.
I'm sure both Jon and I will
be doing stints in that.
You'll definitely be
able to find us there.
And then I'll also be presenting
at East Coast Game Conference
as well.
Fantastic.
Well Jon, it's been a delight
and a pleasure hanging out
with you as always.
JON FOUST: As always.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
And thank you everyone
for listening,
and we'll see you all next week.
JON FOUST: See you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]